space
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
here we go it's been a while since we've
done one of these because it's not
election season but this is a big one
tonight so you can use the uh the
hashtag hashtag Crider Town Hall uh
tonight we're going to be streaming at
eight Eastern because we're in central
so I always have to go through the
anguish of adding one
they'll be doing a Donald Trump
presidential Town Hall Republican town
hall with GOP voters and uh we'll be
streaming it live in live fact checking
the fact Checkers the promo code going
on right now Lottery with credit.com mug
Club you entered the promo code Crowder
town hall right you get 10 pattern down
hall you get 10 off or we still have the
promo if you send in your screenshot of
proof of purchase of any right-leaning
streaming service to uh what what is the
email it's a free mug club
atlanta.com we give you three months
free if you don't like it you can bounce
so just send in your screenshot uh a lot
to get to tonight so what do you expect
comment below hit like if you're on room
if you're on YouTube you should head on
over to rumble there you go dang
uh before I get to the drinking game
rules we have Gerald a in studio and he
is sick he's playing his flu game
tonight I am playing My Flu Game but
don't worry I came prepared the cures
all that ails yeah yes yeah I don't
think that's actually how it works but
maybe if it's I think if it's mold with
spices well maybe some rum would do that
I don't know I have no oh yeah Spiced
Rum that's right but not all rum is
spice Gerald already he gets it wrong he
gets it wrong what kind of pirate are
you anyway well not a good one I think
it's implied also uh to my left you're
right so you have to do the stage he's
you're technically upstage a little bit
for the audience knowledge terminology
are you playing his theme music yeah
yeah bring it up it's ranking he's going
to be in uh New Brunswick New Jersey see
I'm thinking of the province press
factory May 11th through the 13th so you
can go to briancan.com for more dates
looking forward to tonight I'm excited I
have my clipboard I don't know what's on
here but it looks official well you
would if you did the prep my finger when
I turned the page now they don't call it
the best color man of the business for
nothing just don't do it with a comic
book because that take makes its street
value from fifteen thousand dollars to
nothing I didn't know I found that out
but it's my saliva man I'm a celebrity
so so we have a drinking game tonight by
the way you gotta already make an
adjustment here you could happen I gotta
get well I can use my stage voice in the
lower third there uh Tool Man uh the
drinking game rules I'll make sure I
have these uh rules you can play along
with us and uh send in your uh I don't
know your sloshed pictures anytime you
hear any of the above you take a drink
if you hear January 6th boom if you hear
excuse me if you hear the words
indictment or impeachment anytime
there's a thug life moment and anytime
Donald Trump insults the host can I ask
for you finish your drink number two
please because I don't think that was
fair I I need it anytime you hear excuse
me excuse me excuse me excuse you excuse
me excuse me excuse you you should be
I'm excusing no I excuse you excuse me I
won't be sipping my wine I'll be
swilling my one we also by the way
because uh title 42 is ending uh so we
actually have some correspondence
tonight we have well first well first
off we go now live to the Border we have
a live border cam
well that is tough we also have a live
Biden cam tonight so we actually managed
to we spared no expense with a camera
over there at the White House to see
what's going on and Thomas Finnegan is
on the ground tonight yeah at the Town
Hall fantastic uh so what do you guys
expect tonight here's what I will say
and bring it up there in the lower box
so that people know it's uh it's ready
to go there tool man I expect the world
to remember what they liked about Donald
Trump tonight I expect it to be bias uh
uh but you have Caitlin Collins I can
hear a little boy out there
all right well that's fine Hey look it's
older fatter Josh Gad on CNN
and uh oh very good uh hang out nicely
uh this uh it's Caitlin Collins is going
to be doing this tonight she's had a lot
of run-ins with Donald Trump right I
expect there to be by uh intense biases
and we'll be fact checking that I expect
it to be tilted and I expect them to
start with the premise that is alive and
watching CNN all day so you don't have
to where they've been talking about
Donald Trump losing the civil lawsuit by
the way not sexual assault battery this
is battery and they change the statute
of limitations just last year so that it
would extend yeah creep into
Thanksgiving this year so that they
could say that's battery
um they're going to be bringing that up
and they were talking about it today and
they said how does this hurt Trump how
does this hurt Donald Trump and Jake
Tapper uh said along with one of his
lackeys well you know for people who are
always trumped they'll still be always
Trump but this may affect the
Republicans who who are mostly focused
on winning a general they don't want to
acknowledge that the last two polls have
Donald Trump beating by in a general and
buy more than DeSantis doesn't matter
where you line up those are the that's
the definition of fake news you do not
have to start with right now oh all this
bombastic prickishness that's why Donald
Trump beats Joe Biden by a wider margin
by a heftier margin than DeSantis so I
expect them to be biased I expect them
to not really face up to that fact right
now because the whole narrative is if
you want Donald Trump okay he has his
base but he won't win in a general that
doesn't seem to be the case and I expect
him to bring up the uh the fake uh
sexual assault and by that I mean he
wasn't actually he wasn't actually found
guilty of sexual assault just battery
and defamation yeah well and he'll
appeal that I'm assuming that I assume
you can appeal a civil verdict I don't
know man I'm not I'm not a legal scholar
over here on here I know right exactly
wouldn't you say that people are are
tuning in though to see Trump go off Off
Script because you know he's been
coached a certain way but we want to see
more of what he did in the deposition
he's just such a loose cannon he is that
you never know and this could be
historic yeah I think it's going to
introduce people to Donald Trump all
over again which is great it's like
renewing your vows it's a must watch TV
let's be honest CNN and you made a good
point why they have Caitlin Collins and
by the way for those who don't know
killing Collins is the one with Harry
forums at CNN go ahead I thought it was
a little bit weird because you've got
Jake Tapper and you've got Wolf Blitzer
these two and it's not because they're
men don't get me wrong I'll get to that
point just they're not men well they're
not men
macchiatos
freaking beats a lot of the hosts said
CNN weren't men even though they were
men
um if you know what I mean the I think
the problem is that you you put kind of
an attractive younger woman out there
with Donald Trump so that if Donald
Trump pushes back like he his
characteristic thing to do is to push
back on the news and call them fake news
right it'll look like he's beating up on
somebody right if it's a guy it's a
different story right unless it's
shelter but I think well that's true
they don't bring him back you see him
talking trash about Tucker yeah he's
like Tucker was toxic to Fox News
sponsors have you guys heard of clinical
projection
I'm straight the number one show in all
of cable news what's toxic oh my God
he's defecting exactly no so I think
what you'll hear a lot of from Caitlin
is if if there's a legitimate question
asked by a republican voter right right
GOP Primary that's the people that are
supposed to be in the room you'll hear a
well or actually right from her to try
to press Donald Trump on something where
she would never press Joe Biden and it
also helps set her up to ask him about
yes set it up as though it's he's guilty
of rape or sexual assault right yes and
just
Mr former president right exactly yeah
in so many words and here's the thing
you need to understand people will say
oh you're gas like oh this is just the
attack they use against women uh Gene is
it Gene a character
[Music]
wait is there is it Gene e Carroll I
think it's e Gene her last name is Carol
yes and we know that there's somewhere
and when I say she's an insane person
look this is the person who sued Donald
Trump decades later for a rape that
didn't happen but sexual battery which
means he touched her and she didn't like
it but this is that I have plenty of
Clips just just see this she's crazy
I mean it is a violent assault it is not
I think most people think of rape as
being sexy
let's take a short break
we've got to take a quick break
you're fascinating to talk to
God
you're fast by the way she's booking
she's looking at his shoulder for no
reason she's looking straight at his
chest she's just gone bless you don't
think rape is sex is that is the most
awkward I have seen him like I don't
think she knows that Anderson Cooper's
gay yeah
I think rape is sexy Anderson
she's licking her lips I like me a
silverhead fox he's like I like I like
dick what's going on yeah
yeah this is what you're about to say
something she's just she just she didn't
take her eyes off his delicious torso no
to me you're just a torso to me you're
just a body by the way the guy right now
on CNN bring this up full screen do you
think that this guy believes he's
fooling anybody with that haircut like
do you think that he's sitting there
like yeah no it's like Frank Luntz no
one's the wiser they're looking at my
shitty sneakers
so your sneakers are not your face looks
tight for a 50 year old so um I'm trying
to think what what do we think are the
most important clips for people to see
here I think probably some clips between
Collins and Donald Trump yeah I think
that's probably the best right so she
obviously she was I'll go through a
couple of things really quickly in 2014
hired by The Daily Caller 2017 Daily
Caller White House correspondent moved
over to CNN in 2017.
um and actually said that obviously the
Daily Caller this is a quote from her is
a more ideologically aligned
organization than CNN which is worldwide
and has such a range of coverage trying
to get hired much I think right yeah um
it seems a little bit weird there but
then she's named uh 2021 CNN chief White
House correspondent uh by who owned a
chief right I just want to hear Trump do
you think what is he over under Trump
looks at her and goes you're not my type
either yeah
let's you know what tweet in you can
tweet escrow use the hashtag Crowder
Town Hall let's see who thinks that's a
good I bet you that's going to happen I
got to hear that guarantee because if
she starts pressing him he's gonna yeah
I'll be honest I'll say it again I don't
want to be rude you're not my type
you're not my type either I wouldn't
want to Swoon you
you're not no excuse me excuse me you're
not in my tape don't take it personally
a lot of people because my type frankly
excuse me is
pretty I like good looking attractive I
notice Gerald used that term loosely
tonight Caitlin attractive Ryan it's
just what he that's what people don't
tell me I would never say that and
that's my excuse me that's my type and
you're frankly not that right your teeth
are too small so it's just it's just
personal preference I like pretty women
I like feminine women I like women who
are good looking I like women who
they're attractive and you're not you're
not that's how we would get a real way
with words Mr President ten minutes
later she's like okay yeah so let's show
you this is the person they chose to do
this town hall with Donald Trump who by
the way beats Joe Biden former Vice
President Biden by a wide margin right
now by even more than DeSantis they're
pretty close DeSantis and Donald Trump
are within the margin of error as far as
uh by how much they beat Biden but they
are not within the margin of error
according to ABC and wash Washington
Post now two polls in a row in beating
Biden so this is damage control I expect
this to be a way to try and kneecap
Donald Trump to try and Tanya Harding
and before he gets started and that's
why they picked the hairy forum lady at
CNN let's show you a montage of their
interactions that have been contentious
you ran your campaign promising
supporters that Mexico is going to pay
for the world the wall was going to be
made
I know you all could be made of steel
and right now our government is shut
down over a demand from your
Administration that the American
taxpayer pay for the wall so how can you
say you're not failing on that promise
to your supporters uh very nice question
so beautifully asked even though I just
answered
that you have the authority to decide
when they're stated
you know why because I don't have to I
think it was a fake report done by CNN
no that's enough go ahead of my question
the problem is you know what the truth
so you know as far as I'm concerned I
want to go I want to go to the next one
last week real quick thank you very much
everybody thank you
so is she the one that's is that that's
the one who's conducting this tonight oh
wow yeah okay yeah and don't remember
that or don't forget they actually
brought her into kind of co-host the
morning show that has been so wonderful
with Don Lemon yeah and uh Poppy Harlow
yes and obviously there's a montage
there but we can go to it later because
I think
[Music]
all Trump appear on CNN at all uh I
think I know your opinion Brian do you
think it's a good idea I do indeed I see
I knew you would say that I think you're
right because I think correct me if I'm
wrong I think you're predicating this on
reaching other people right having voice
having a dialogue across the aisle well
I I I'm more interested in engaging I
like that he's engaging with the in the
belly of the bed and I agree he's in the
mall in the round I agree with that
except for the fact that CNN has no
audience if not for Donald Trump it's
the same reason that you know you don't
just debate every single Twitter egg
Donald Trump is giving they need Donald
Trump he can use that to his Advantage
I'm making your ratings you need me that
that to me is is a pretty cool at card
that's a good point but I think I think
unfortunately they're so short-sighted
they don't care they still want to get
rid of do you not think he should would
you have advised him not to I think that
Donald Trump he should have done it just
independently it's what I think that's
what he should at least the first
go-around should have done it for
example he does some stuff on rumble or
whether it be
CNN yeah he should have done it first
that way he can it's almost like uh
shopping the shopping and around people
go oh my gosh look at what he did he did
way bigger numbers than our Network
could do with him and then he says you
know who what's um who what's the
biggest numbers at that point then he
can maybe have some influence but what
about the the cache he gets from being
able to beat or at least engage with
people who he knows have a bias against
him I don't think that's why he's doing
it though I think he's doing it because
he's mad at Fox News and rightfully so
because I think more damaging than lies
or even Lies by Omission which are very
damaging it goes It goes this way what's
most damaging with the media okay lies
outright lies bias that would be like
MSNBC okay but everyone knows what
they're getting Lies by Omission that
would be CNN once once upon a time when
they had actual ratings right even more
dangerous or half truths and that's what
you get at Fox News and I think that
Donald Trump feels really burned by that
because he knows that they were actively
trying to collude against him to use the
word and they were supposed to be out
it's very different when someone puts on
your team jersey yeah right it ends up
being like in Christian to be apostasy
so let's look at CNN they just had there
by the way lowest rated month in a
decade you know what their numbers were
during Prime Time what 122 000. ain't
close to Crowder sorry narrowed it out
loud and by the way Nary a demo viewer
Mary demo I think this was just Bill
Devane to watch 122 000 times let me
just check my yep that's what it says
right there so it's terrible man so
lowest rated month they fired Brian
stelter they fired down lemon CNN plus
was canceled after two weeks it was less
than a month yeah so they need Donald
Trump and he really is giving them a leg
up and uh you guys comment look you tell
me what you guys think I I have two
minds about it um I think you should
have done it independently first so you
know what I think would have been a
great thing to do and I'm serious he
should have said pay me a million
dollars yes for real like you want me on
you you want me on you pay me pay me pay
me half the issue advertising Revenue
just awarded to that crazy broad Carol
five million I don't know five million
dollars or maybe five million batteries
you can get me pay my legal fees
Energizer none of that none of that
generic so there's two things that
I like about this one this could be an
epic troll right because he knows CNN is
going to get absolutely lambasted right
for this and he already have right and
people are going to be mad at him but
pair this with he said he's not going to
do the first debate in the first debate
in August is on what network Fox right
right so he's it's a bit of a power play
but it's also a pretty cool troll
because CNN can't win no it's true yeah
what happens is
he has stopped She have to watch this
ratings this rating Spike and then
like a fight in the wind God forever it
really is I mean it's so much more
because it's it's more painful to have
loved Brian and lost they say all right
touch me again some say that well I
don't want a good time oh sorry by the
way your sweater's pilling yeah this is
how I say Kashmir yeah I do I got it
from the Cashmere Valley everyone I
don't even think they call it that there
that's true at all I have no idea uh so
use that Pro soft on the top so hard
Crowder Town Hall sorry little it's fine
mug club and of course Crowder town hall
is the hashtag is she preparing right
now the one in the white pants you don't
know you were battering me I don't know
there's one more minute Donald Trump's
like I'll come out when I'm ready yes
you can take his time there's a lot of
Tony Clifton and Donald Trump there
really is he's just sitting back there
I'm loving up my vocal cords
[Laughter]
if you smoked he would blow the
cigarette in her face
you know this makes him look Brave
though right like he's like bring it on
he doesn't care yeah I just help him now
I want him to come out as Tony Cliff I
know right that'd be great now Caitlyn
Khan I think the white pants don't make
you look more slim take the attention
off your forearms ah you should come out
in a Biden mask ah there's wolf Lois
score everyone Celebrity Jeopardy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
college for CNN's town hall with former
president Donald Trump I'm Caitlin just
here from the background
unlike any other in the history of U.S
presidential elections he's the first
president in more than a century to seek
a return to the White House and he is
currently leading the Republican field
while also facing multiple criminal
investigations and an indictment
indictments
at the table and we agreed today we're
here to get voters the answers that they
deserve our audience is made up of
Republicans and
[Laughter]
Donald Trump
foreign
[Laughter]
that's the dynamic that he literally
sets up he answers to them not to Harry
Forum Caitlin uh Caitlyn Caitlin Collins
president Trump thank you for your time
here tonight we've got a great crowd
here in New Hampshire a lot of Voters uh
with a lot of questions about what your
2024 term would look like more of the
same would look like
shortly but I killed it before so that
you were dominating the Republican race
right now but you were also under active
federal investigation for trying to
overturn the 2020 election results
20 election results why should Americans
put you back in the White House because
we did fantastically we got 12 million
more votes than we had in as you know in
2016. I actually say we did far better
in that election got the most uh that
anybody's ever gotten as a city
president of the United States uh I
think that when you look at that result
and when you look at what happened
during that election unless you're a
very stupid person
it's a shame that we had to go through
it it's very bad for our country all
over the world they looked at it and
they saw exactly what everyone else uh
you look even if you just look recently
with the 51 intelligence agents that
made a 16 point difference uh if you
look at the FBI president if you look at
the FW he paused for a second then
decided no I'm not getting a difference
if you look at it back to what you just
said there though it was not a rigged
election it was not a stolen election
you and your supporters lost more than
60 court cases on the election it's been
nearly two and a half years can you
publicly acknowledge that you did lose
the 2020 election let me just go if you
look at trees they found millions of
votes on camera on government cameras
where they were stuffing ballot boxes so
with all of that I think it's a shame
that what happened I think it's a very
sad thing for our country I think it's a
very sad thing frankly for the world
because if you look at what's gone to
our country our country has gone to Hell
our borders are bad our military has
been bad you look at the taxes you look
at inflation what's happened to
inflation it's just destroying our
country it's really inflated we've
really become in many ways a third world
country and it's very sad it's a strong
strong start yeah something that we'll
turn around on day one we're energy
independent now energy is at a level
that we've never had to pay before we
nobody can afford to continue to pay
what's happening with energy no it's not
we're energy he's coming out he's
setting the pace right now where he's
listing his accomplishments that
contrast is really valuable and that way
he can't allow her to just tilt it right
away she tried to go immediately
election and he didn't okay policy
tonight but but what you just said there
Republican officials debunked those
claims about fraudulent ballots we want
to give you a chance tonight who
Republican officials in Georgia State
there is no your own election officials
Mr President so we wanted to be afraid
to take on the issue but we have a big
problem in this country
he has not a chance calling it right now
this is what people want you may try
people may try and Gaslight you thank
you
[Music]
so you're making tonight from voters on
this topic I want to bring in Scott
Dustin from Concord he works in
Insurance litigation he's an undercluded
[Applause]
Scott what's your question for the
president
welcome back to New Hampshire thank you
will you suspend the polarizing talk of
election fraud during your president
will I suspend excuse my what will you
suspend polarizing talk of election
fraud yeah that's a typical Republican
for president I talked to Republicans by
the way conservatives every day never
once would I expect to hear them say
will you suspend polarizing election
talk right exactly so it's also January
6th drink we have our first fact check
actually if we can get a a fact check
really quickly here so 50 of them those
60 cases were dismissed before being
heard not lost exactly that's what
Caitlyn said you lost 60 cases 50 that
was great good job research team yep 50
thrown out or not even going to trial
not even being heard just dismissed they
didn't even go through the they didn't
even go through the trouble of changing
a statute of limitations and changing
the law so they could extend it that
takes planning yeah with sexual battery
by the way I do believe he commits
sexual battery this guy because he keeps
going and going and go let's go tonight
sounds like he uh
suggested hey I guess he had a good
answer call the crane shot Constitution
do you stand by those comments I don't
know you were able to do certain things
I'm not talking about terminating the
Constitution I'm talking about
cherishing the Constitution the
Constitution says it was supposed to
have legal and well maintained and well
looked at elections and we didn't have
that I cherish our constitution but we
have to live up to the Constitution we
weren't living up to the Constitution
there's no evidence of that election
fraud you didn't want
to verbal election and unless somebody's
very stupid and I know you very well
you're not stupid at all but you perhaps
are given an agenda or you have an
agenda we have to have honest elections
in our country we have open borders we
have
you look at what's happening I mean we
have that white guy in the vest looked
pissed
and millions of people are coming here
they're being released from prisons
they're being released from mental
institutions and we have millions of
people pouring into our country and now
they're getting rid of title 42 which I
put on which kept people out that were
sick and Mr President we have a lot of
questions about immigration to get to
tonight obviously that's a big topic
especially given what's expected to
happen tomorrow but I want to talk about
the influence you have over your voters
it's very clear that you are very
influential over them you have a lot of
impact I've been to many of your rallies
and seen it up close which raised a lot
of questions about the influence that we
saw that you had on them on January 6th
and you're surprised
I need more friend needs more red wine
you know uh January 6 was again we go
back to it but January 6 had to do with
the fact that hundreds one right now
send in our new uh new intern because of
title 42. it was the largest crowd I've
ever spoken to that was prior to the
walk down to the Capitol Building I
don't think and I've spoken to hundreds
of thousands of people I've never spoken
to a crowd as large as this and that was
because they thought the election was
rigged and they were there proud they
were there with love in their heart that
was an unbelievable and it was a
beautiful day and what I was asked to do
I wasn't involved in it very much I was
asked to come in would I make a speech I
made a speech I said walk peacefully and
patriotically you know many different
things in fact I brought a list of
things I didn't want to bore the
audience you never hear the ghost
sentence you have to sentence after
sentence of things I said and things I
put out one of the big problems was that
Nancy now the media is going to say he
called January 6th the beautiful day
yeah
really quickly so in total three
quarters of Voters said that they think
some fraud occurred right this poll was
conducted shortly after the election in
the ugov.com so I'm just I'm just saying
and only three quarters thought that
there was there was
[Music]
thank you
ladies and soldiers if they would have
taken 500 soldiers you wouldn't have the
problem they turned it down and if you
look at the Inspector General report he
says they turned it down they made a
terrible mistake well Chris Miller was
your acting defense secretary he says
you never gave that order but back to
ducting an unbiased town hall right
she's literally refuting him and by the
way wrongly wrongly she's refuting what
is what is a matter of record with
hearsay well he said this you want to
bring up uh Cassidy
what's her name remember that Cassie
Hutchinson yes oh yeah yeah oh yeah
scary jerk the wheel that's really were
you there well I wasn't in the car I
wasn't in the next zip code but you know
because he's reaching in his pocket all
right he has a list of things he said oh
here we go here we go hey look Weasley
my pocket he's got props
on January 5th the day before I said
please support our Capitol Police at law
enforcement they are truly on the side
of our country stay peaceful stay
peaceful this was the day before and
this was in the form of Twitter now use
truth truth social I think it's far
superior
2 30.
I am asking for everyone at the U.S
Capitol to remain peaceful this is right
after as it was happening but what
happened is they took it down I don't
know why I think they took it down
because it was so good they didn't like
it being up I am asking this is and we
didn't know until I got it back because
now I have 90 million people waiting for
me to go back but I'm unsure that I'm
staying on truth I am asking for
everyone
I'd like my wine please I'm good that
was very early Mr President I looked at
the same timeline that you did
thank you we did report it was taken
down when it was clear to you that they
were not being peaceful you saw them
rushing the capitol breaking Windows
they were hitting officers with
flagpoles tasing them beating them up
when it was clear they weren't being
peaceful why did you wait three hours to
tell them to leave the capitol they
already told them to be peaceful before
that you know that's why I do I agree
with that so why is he Pelosi Nancy
Pelosi and the mayor are in charge I
assumed they were able to do their job
think of the standard he preemptively
said be peaceful then he's out there
giving it he asked for them to uh to to
increase the capital police but he made
the request then he's out there and
they're saying why didn't you do it
right then he we didn't know what was
going on on the ground by the way we
didn't know that feds were going to show
up and raid their own cap Why didn't
down there in person you know oh what
was a big clap let me see what he said
I'm sorry it was a beautiful video and
it said I mean I don't want to read at
all but you have but I will have to go
home now
we have to have peace we have to have
Law and Order we have to respect our
great people of Law and Order we love
the people of Law and Order we can't
play into the show lines
we have to have peace please go home
you know what they did they took the
bread down and you know to this day it
hasn't been put up and the reason is
it's so good and so conclusive that all
of this nonsense and all of the tens of
millions of dollars that have been spent
are just wiped away with the fact check
for her so D.C mayor Muriel what is it
Bowser or something like Bowser
requested unarmed Guardsmen and said
they should not help with the protests
and evidence does point to Nancy Pelosi
denying those requests of course from
Donald Trump saying hey would you like
Guardsmen nope why would you do that
unless you were ready for something to
go she's on record of saying no yeah
also there were many feds there so you
know yeah yeah yeah you know we can you
can call it a conspiracy by the way all
references are available at live with
credit.com we have tons today of prep
that I don't know if we'll necessarily
get to because this is just a fun house
as it is the promo code is Crowder town
hall light of color.com you get ten
dollars off or you get three months free
if you've subscribed anywhere else to
any other streaming service let's
continue watching this man spank her
Athletics
you just give and she was a good person
there was no reason there was no good
for him and
he went on television she's stumbling
she doesn't know where to go with this
officer was not bragging about the fact
that he killed her but one person who
was at the Capitol that day as you know
was your vice president Mike Pence who
says that you
[Music]
the vice president does not have the
authority to reject them
because it's interesting let's keep it
interesting right
now he's a very nice man he made a
mistake his lawyer said
you cannot move I call them the human
conveyor belt I said even if the votes
you mean even if the votes are
absolutely fraudulent he can't yes sir
he canceled but and the Democrats played
it and the Rhinos played it and then the
election was over they told him he
couldn't do it and Mike said to me I
can't do it the lawyers told me you
can't do it they can't do it but the
lawyers were wrong because right after
the election they all met the rhinos and
the Democrats and they worked out a plan
to make sure that future vice presidents
don't do what I said you could do that's
not what happened you referred to the
Electoral account I've read that there
is there is no Authority no legal
experts including Republicans
why did they change the law then saying
that you can't do it they didn't change
the law they strengthened the law
because they were worried about
questions meaning you could do it
I think Caitlyn thought that this was
going to be her coming out party and
instead she's getting run over by a tank
yeah it's back to Georgia Pennsylvania
other states Wisconsin which Gerald your
prediction was would have been right if
she wasn't so bumba if she wasn't so
caustic that's true she does come across
as unlikable yeah right now yes just in
general
come back in the affirmation she owns no
upper lip well you just said it she's
kind of admitted what I said was there's
a purity to her outfit yes that's true
the right to do it it's called a lie and
he says why does it have driven snow
that's why they changed the law take in
that right away but a black heart I
should note that your campaign paid
first account that happened in Wisconsin
it actually had more votes for President
Biden by the end of it was something
about recounting that wasn't the problem
next
[Laughter]
easy and he always says there's a golf
ball at his head he's great I love him I
do want to get to the audience so we
have questions for you from the audience
can I get some ibuprofen please I'm
laughing too much
thank you for coming Mr President Mike
my pres my question to you is will you
pardon the January 6th yeah important
question you should have done that a
federal offense I am inclined to Pardon
many of them but I can say for every
single one because a couple of them
probably they got out of control but you
know when you look at antifa what
they've done to Portland and if you look
at antifa look at what they've done to
Minneapolis and so many other so many
other places look at what they did he's
doing really well he answered the
question by the way he answered the
question clearly said for a lot of them
maybe not all of them and then took the
fight to where he's strongest that's the
equivalent to a takedown he's like you
know what I don't want to just stick on
my feet here because they're going to
try and do the stand back and stand by
with the proud boys so I'm going to
answer it clearly and then move on to
something that I know will resonate this
is a look you guys comment send me your
comments uh Crowder Town Hall I think
he's doing a really really good job my
my answer is I am most likely if I get
in I will most likely I would say it
will be a large portion of them you know
they did a very
and it'll be very early on
and they're living in hell right now so
when it comes to delivered in hell and
the policemen and their firemen and
their soldiers and their carpenters and
electricians she might as well not even
be there people many of them are just
great people Mr President one of the
people who was convicted was a former
policeman but he was convicted of
attacking a police officer I should note
but when you said you are considering
pardoning a large portion of those
charged with crimes on January 6. does
that include the four proud boys members
who are charged and convicted
I don't know I'd have to look at their
case but I will say in Washington D.C
you cannot get a fair trial you can it's
100 true you can't get a fair trial
he took it
yeah he just he just slapped his wiener
on the table said take a look
massive
reviews the writer Eugene Carroll and
defamed her you've denied this but what
do you say to voters by the way so did
the court yeah
my poll numbers just came out they went
up
[Applause]
like that and usually you leave office
you say I'm sorry but I'm going to back
home I'm back home to my family and
everything I'm going to be reside my
poll numbers went up and they went up
with the other fake charge too because
what's happening is they're doing this
for election interference this woman I
don't know her I never met her I have no
idea who she is I had a picture taken
years ago with her and her husband nice
guy John by the way she was funded by a
Democrat Mega donor just to be clear
Reed Hoffman the co-founder yep LinkedIn
Reed Hoffman uh anti-trumper yep huge
backup Hillary Clinton just to be clear
and by the way there was a deposition
where she said that no one was actually
paying her legal fee so that's a lie
that's perjury that would be important
you would think and there was a but
there was a bunch of Foul Play there I
think the most important of which is the
fact that they changed the statute of
limitations and he committed no sexual
assault it's battery which means any
kind of touching that's unwanted let's
hear Caitlin Collins trying to
no I don't think so because I think the
whole thing
just so you understand ready
I never met this woman I never saw this
woman this woman said I met her at the
front door of Bergdorf Goodwin which I
rarely go into other than for a couple
of charities
I met her in the front door she was
about 60 years old and this is like 22
23 years ago I met her in the front door
at Bergdorf Goodman I was immediately
attracted to her she was immediately
attracted to me and we this is what she
said had this great chemistry we're
walking into a crowded department so we
had this great chemistry and a few
minutes later we end up in a a room a
dressing room a book of Goodman right
near the cash register and then she
found out there were locks in the door
so she said I found one that was open
she found one she learned this at trial
she found one that was open kind of a
woman needs somebody and brings them up
and within minutes you're playing
hanky-panky in a dressing room okay I
don't know if he was she was married
then or not John Johnson I feel sorry
for you John
uh
he's got to be careful he's got to be
careful here yeah no just so you
understand if I was walking in because I
was very famous then and I owned the
Plaza Hotel right next door and I own
buildings around it I'm not going into
addressing room of a crowded department
store then I say if she was being raped
and by the way they said she wasn't
raped okay that was her judge said they
found it they did they found her what
say what that they did they said he
didn't
I didn't do anything else either you
know what because I have no idea who the
hell she is
[Music]
which I'd never do I have no idea who
this woman this is a fake Story made up
story we had a horrible Clinton
appointed judge he was horrible he
allowed her to put everything in he
allowed us was appointed by Clinton in
1990 94. now to the audience you
reference the trial you did not go to
the trial and actually testify do you
wish that you had testified it wouldn't
have made a difference this is a rig
deal this was a my lawyer did you see
the deposition I killed it and by the
way I know here's what the media wants
you to believe oh regular oh rig trial
oh I guess everyone's ringing against
you maybe you're the problem that's the
by the way we this has happened across
the board with people they don't like
they did the same thing to George W no
one can defend himself yeah I've lived
it what happens is they pile on and they
try and make it seem as though everyone
can't be wrong but it's all come coming
from the same place exactly that's
what's going on right here and that's
why he's not apologizing no one can
defend themselves against this kind of
thing no if someone gets a story and you
get nothing and somebody says after 23
years or whatever it is there's nothing
you can do right no fix is in man the
fix is in by the way really quickly
another fact check all right the
Electoral count Act of 2022 changed the
Electoral count Act of 1887 it was kind
of time to kind of you know brush that
one up makes it harder for Congress to
challenge the state slate of electors
and the VP role now is purely ceremonial
so yes it's a new thing it's a new thing
it wasn't purely ceremonial before now
there's some power to be fair there was
some argument about it yes but there was
arguments about it enough that they said
we need to make sure there's no leeway
here so you can't say that he was
factually incorrect when what he said
was factually correct all references
available at lottery.com there certainly
is a gray area but they eliminated the
gray area because they knew it let's go
back million years approximately a
million years perhaps a little little
bit longer than that so you stand by
those cars
paleontologists we disagree
has no advantage over anywhere else well
you do have an advantage and I say
unfortunately but that's the way it is
you said fortunately or unfortunately
fortunately unfortunately for her
questions to get to tonight I want to go
back to the audience let's just recap
this oh hold on a second let's go
assistant she's a republican activist
from Derry she's a New Hampshire
Delegate for you love milk what's your
question big fan hi thank you so much
for coming to New Hampshire to answer
our questions my question is regarding
the economy over the past two years we
have seen the prices for everything
Skyrocket from food to gas to utilities
and insurance costs many people's bills
are up several hundred dollars a month
including mine if elected president
again what is the first thing you would
do to help bring down the cost to make
things more affordable
drill baby drill
[Applause]
consonant politician clear answer wow
no I would say that's not a political
answer that's practical that's advice
that's a practice answer with a
non-answer that's a truthful practical
answer
well down to 1.87 actually it fell lower
than that in something so he's going to
talk about gas prices so really quickly
guys uh let's uh we actually spent we
spent a lot of money spared no expense
so really quickly let's check in with
our very first Biden Cam and see what
former Vice President Joe Biden is up to
because you know this answer
and if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or Trump and you
ain't black
[Music]
thank you
if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or Trump and you
ain't black all right and we're back I
don't know why we spent that much money
could have predicted how it goes let's
see what Donald Trump is still is he
still talking about oil because I get
got you the biggest tax cuts in the
history of our country bigger than the
Reagan cuts
by the way if you're watching right now
uh on you wherever you are hit the
rumble button you can hit share you can
hit like whatever it is uh wherever you
are right now hit that
you're good to go yeah yeah and China
paid a big price and let me tell you
something I took in hundreds of billions
of dollars in taxes from China but prior
to covet coming in and then I rebuilt
the economy again a second time but we
had prior to covet coming in as as from
China from Wuhan which I said it came
from Wuhan everybody said oh you're
wrong about that you're wrong it came
from Wuhan I said it right from day one
it's so wrong we had the greatest
economy in the world here's the story
they made energy so high and energy is
all invasive it is massive as an
industry and as a cost it lifted
everything if you made donuts no matter
what you did she might as well not be
there and we had inflation the likes of
which I guess this pisses off AOC we
actually have a quote from her a tweet
CNN should be ashamed of themselves they
have lost total control of this town
hall to be again manipulated into
platforming election disinformation
defenses of January 6 in a public attack
on a sexual abuse victim this audience
is cheering him on and laughing at the
host oh yeah but when she tries to tweet
she sees two screens well that's fair
away from defaulting on its debt that
can mean millions of jobs lost people
not getting their Social Security
payments people believe it this is why
Trump will win there could be millions
of jobs lost people right now are
struggling yeah Collins people right now
they're so disconnected from reality
people right now can't afford eggs they
can't afford beef people right now they
have their jobs available but they're
shitty jobs because half of the economy
you don't need a fact check that it's
not actually half but the point is the
economy as we knew it was fundamentally
changed restaurants entertainment venues
these people have lived it and CNN this
is why you just hit an all-time month
low in the single hundred thousand range
I think was 132 000 was your Peak Prime
Time viewership last month because you
don't acknowledge what people are living
because they don't know what people are
living yeah no they I I think some of
them don't I think some of them know and
they're trying to re-engineer it anyway
they're trying to lie anyway I think
some of them are maybe Harry forearm
girl because she's not died in the wall
but she just given marching orders come
on she's a she's a patsy in a white
pantsuit for the higher ups yep yeah
they came in Schumer came in
and they were using a wheel violate it
we'll do whatever they talked a whole
lot different than they do right now I
say that the Republicans out there
Congressman Senators if they don't give
you massive cuts
you're gonna have to do a default
and I don't believe they're going to do
it before because I think the Democrats
will absolutely cave because you don't
want to have that happen but it's better
than what we're doing right now because
we're spending money like drunken
Sailors so just to be clear Mr President
you think the U.S should default if the
white house does not agree to the
spending cuts Republicans we might as
well do it now because you'll do it
later
you have to make the cut by the way just
to be clear this is something that CNN
was having uh they were hosting this
today with Biden he just went out and
lied Biden uh just I believe yesterday
and then they kept running it today on a
loop he said that he's cut the deficit
by 1.7 trillion dollars uh and what he
tried to do is sort of he tried to
Parlay that into the debt look the debt
is the cumulative which is over 30
trillion dollars right now the deficit
means your profits and losses basically
at an annual basis right so it's the
year the spending differential three
trillion dollars the national debt has
increased since Biden took office just
to be clear 30 trillion comparing his
2022 deficit to Donald Trump's 2020
deficit
uh it was a 1.3 trillion dollars for
Biden Donald Trump was 3.3 trillion both
Presidents by the way spent more than
they brought in that's a problem that he
should address
but again a big part of it was 900
billion dollars was a was a coveted Bill
When Donald Trump they're always going
to try and point to his last year right
to his last portion of his presidency
because that was something that they
could engineer under the basis of a
pandemic Joe Biden is spending more
money just to be clear Joe Biden's plan
increases spending will increase the
debt they don't want to address that so
they say oh if they're Joe Biden hasn't
answered on cuts
the answer is to increase taxes watch
him answer the questions he never
actually answers as to what he would cut
we don't have a tax problem you can even
if you think we do we certainly have a
spending problem sure right a trillion
dollars is 1 000 billion yeah and if you
add the reparations they want in
California it would be 430 something
trillion dollars just for California
just for California they'd be they'd be
paid for by blacks from Uganda racism is
expensive hey it's Alex Keaton
look-alike Foundation hi thank you for
coming this is a bit of a pivot but uh
with gun violence and mass shootings in
the news cycle recently I'm worried that
state governments and the federal
government are going to ask to repress
gun rights under your Administration you
instructed the Department of Justice and
the ATF to ban bump stocks if elected
president again how would you ask not
only to defend our Second Amendment
rights but to restore good question from
a question that a lot of Second
Amendment activists would want to ask
Donald Trump he screwed up on that one
let's see his answer stabilizing braces
yeah as you know the bump stocks are
actually a very unimportant thing and
NRA I went with them and they said it
doesn't mean anything they're actually
all they do is teach you how to shoot
very inaccurately so we did that this
has been nobody not a good answer though
it's not a good answer though Donald
Trump not easy to do but we have a very
big mental health problem in this
country and the bread and the pantsuit
knows Zoloft is it Paxil and we have to
protect
us
dealt with a lot of mass shootings when
you were in office this year there have
already been more than 200 mass
shootings in 2023 if you are re-elected
are there any new gun restrictions that
you would sign into law zero numerous
things for instance schools we would
Harden very very much hardened and I
also I'm a very believer I believe in
teachers I love teachers I think they're
incredible and they love the children
not quite like the parents but they love
the children in many cases almost as
much many of these teachers are soldiers
ex-soldiers ex-policemen they're people
that really understand weapons and you
don't need five percent of the teachers
would be more than you could ever have
if you're a teacher security guards but
in addition to that have security guards
you have to harden your entrances you
have to make schools safe and you can
make other places safe but it is a big
mental health problem in this country
more than anything else and remember we
have 700 million guns 700 by the way you
this is I think we're breaking we have
um some new uh a new Tucker Carlson oh
yeah yeah
in that's right yeah absolutely that's
right
[Music]
uh let me see here what is uh do we know
what the Tucker do you have it hoodie
the latest Tucker bomb show I do yeah
this is breaking right email on Twitter
um subject Tucker Carlson's disregard
for workplace sanitization
a janitor said Mr Tucker was tossing a
ball of paper into the trash and he
missed and I could tell that he didn't
intend to pick it up okay
yeah that's the that's what's on Twitter
right now it's the bomb
is there anything else do we have uh
is there anything else that we have
[Music]
all right well more on that uh Crowder
town hall 10 off on mug Club let's go
back to Donald Trump races also all of
those places are the worst and most
dangerous places so that's not the
answer no new restrictions that you
would sign if re-elected Mr President I
want you to meet Julie miles a
registered nurse from Mary Mac she's a
republican who noticed that she tries
let me try and uh let me try and rebut
you before I go to the question for the
person answering this question this
evening how do you plan to appeal to
Women Voters in New Hampshire who are
concerned about the Dobbs decision and
how States may change their laws it's
such a great question and it was such a
great Victory and uh people are starting
to understand it now uh you know that
they wanted to bring it back to the
States but that was probably the least
important part of that Victory getting
rid of Roe v Wade was an incredible
thing for pro-life because it gave
pro-life something to negotiate with
pro-life had absolutely nothing being
stuck in Roe v way to negotiate with and
now what's happening and I see it all
over uh deals are being made deals are
going to be made and it look everybody
that was President wanted to get rid and
tried to get rid of Roe v Wade for 50
years Republicans for 50 years this has
been going on actually a couple of
Democrats too but for 50 years by the
way Caitlyn it doesn't affect you if
you're not a if you're not a
this doesn't concern you you're
concerned she's gonna look at her face
she's concerned oh a filthy all
right I believe in the exceptions the
life of the mother raped incest like
Ronald Reagan believed in the exceptions
but I happen to believe that I think it
I think it's frankly important to do
that but a lot of people are you know
against that a relatively small
relatively small number but the way I
the way I look I think it's very
important to say this I consider the
other side to be radical because the
other side under Roe v Wade and other
things the other side they're radical
because they will remember the debate
with Hillary Clinton they said rip the
baby out of the womb at the end of the
ninth month they will kill the baby in
the ninth month if you look at that
crazy governor of Virginia from the
former Governor where he said no the
baby will be born and then we'll keep
comfortable essentially whether or not
to execute Mr President can we talk
about what you would do away from this
oh my gosh the pro-life people that are
right but if you are re-elected and
you're back in the Oval Office and you
get legislation to your desk would you
sign a federal abortion ban into law and
what I'll do is negotiate so that people
are happy but the fact that we were able
I was able I'm so proud of it we put
three great justices on the Supreme
Court we have almost 300 federal judges
here's the lesson anyone else is going
to throw their hat in the ring Caitlyn
Collins doesn't matter you're not
talking to her I've said this many times
with change we've done changed my Minds
we've done countless change my Minds
billions of plays and then we've also
done debates on the show it becomes
harder and harder to do is people don't
necessarily want to have these
conversations across Seattle unless of
course you're talking about every single
Twitter egg but here's the thing you
need to recognize the difference between
Minds you can change and people who are
they're so bought into the LIE they have
to propagate it that's CNN that's
Caitlin Collins and Donald Trump for the
first time that I at least in recent
memory he's identifying the difference
he's identifying maybe people who have
questions that aren't coming straight
from the right in the town hall he's
identifying okay this is someone who
maybe is open to what I have to say this
is someone who has ears to hear she
doesn't she doesn't matter don't cater
to the media bypass them you don't have
to cater to them anymore right this is a
this is a master class in bypassing to
piggyback on that would you say he's the
first candidate in the history of this
country that will actually benefit from
from how unfairly he's treated Bible
media yeah the harder they go the harder
they go the more his ratings will jump
because
Americans no matter where they are like
fair play yes and when they see when
they see a violation of fair play they
kind of instead you know what they
really hate they really hate being
fooled and I think with Donald Trump
they realize you know what we were
fooled with a lot of this yeah I think
uh that's a good point I think he has a
valuable tool it is to is great for the
country and what's fair for the country
but the fact that I was able to
terminate Roe v Wade after 50 years of
trying they worked for 50 years
and I was even I was so honored to have
done it we are in a very good
negotiating position right now only
because of what I was able to do and
remember this again you talk about
radicalism people that will kill a baby
in the ninth month or the eighth month
or the seventh month or after the baby
is born they're the radicals not the
problem
did the same thing with antifa did the
same thing with abortion brilliant let
me hear what she has to say whether or
not you'd sign a federal abortion ban or
how many weeks into pregnancy you
believe
they've never they've never forced a
Democrat to answer for when there is a
limit to terminating pregnancy because
every just to be clear while we're
talking about one thing that Donald
Trump missed while we're talking about
the radicals people say oh extreme left
the extreme right right this is my left
ear right I have to do the stage terms
here's the thing every single person who
has run for the Democratic nomination in
the last two elections
has supported abortion up until and
including birth as a matter of policy
period no exceptions perhaps Tulsi
gabbard and other Republican presidents
and others by the way they wanted to get
it out they also wanted to bring it back
to the States but bringing it back to
the states is a less important issue but
that's why the issue
Stallone said take it back to this
this dude by the trash can he said
is that what he was singing about that's
what he was saying I didn't know that if
that bell rings and I'm still standing I
always say so prophetic I always say I
have the baby anyway in just a moment
all right uh really quickly as they're
about to go to a commercial break we
spared no expense and I believe that we
sent uh
somewhere here I want to make sure that
I have this right that he stood up and
he's ready to go
um Thomas Finnegan uh is actually yep we
have Thomas Finnegan we sent him down to
the town hall on the ground for the
commercial break Let's uh
[Music]
all right at the Town Hall Mr Finnegan
what do you got for us sir hi Stephen it
doesn't look like things have kicked off
yet but I'm glad to be here early to
catch all of the action as it unfolds
where are you I'm at the Town Hall of
course
but where are you
I'm at the Town Hall
in the Hamptons no no For the Love of
for the love of God Thomas You're
supposed to be the Town Hall in New
Hampshire it's politics we're doing
politics Donald Trump presidential town
hall and New Hampshire go there now go
there go
[Music]
quickly we're gonna go to hold on a
second you have a fact check I guess but
really quick hold on let me just say
Brian count will be in New Brunswick New
Jersey May 11th through the 13th boom if
you were on Rumble right now this is
what keeps us going notice there aren't
20 30 40 live reads if you're on Rumble
click that button right down there we're
going to continue doing a mug Club
Exclusive by the way show uh after this
show on CNN it's 89 if you enter in
Crowder town hall or go ahead ten
dollars off on the the discount code
just for tonight that's right ten
dollars off so seventy nine dollars
we've got can we can we get the like an
epic fact check we got a couple here so
something that's a little bit live fact
check for the Crowder no no no no there
you go give it to me
news
there we go all right so nonpartisan
committee for a responsible federal
budget the U.S national debt will
Balloon by nearly 20 trillion dollars
over the next decade under the spending
outlined by President Biden in his 6.9
trillion dollar budget that's a lot of
nuts but it's somebody else's money well
no it well if you if you put it over 10
years it doesn't matter also mass
shootings were lower under Donald Trump
by almost half I don't know why she was
asking him questions about Biden's
policies that have led to more mass
shootings because his mass shooting
numbers were far lower and also I could
answer that because excuse me she's a
lying
I think she's very nice but that's what
people tell me you don't know my body
count she lies and she's a liar
and you know it that's true thank
you I was buying time okay go ahead
no I I think that's that's that that
summarizes some of the fact checks that
we're working on right now and by the
way I just want to add an answer to the
abortion question so my my policy on
abortion is no would you sign a federal
no I don't want to sign a federal ban I
want that to be a state power issue
right I I want that to be in the state's
hands and I want the state's hand to be
moved by the people to do the right
thing right that's what I want I don't
want Federal overreach and stuff like
this even when I think it's something
that benefits me I want it to be in the
hands of the state I think Donald Trump
should say that he didn't he said that
was a less important issue I disagree
with that I think States having the
ability to decide this stuff is very
important because that's exactly what
the Supreme Court struck that's also
that's also what a republic is right
that is what this country I have to go
use the uh the little boys room so let's
really quickly let's check in really
quickly uh and then I'll be back you
guys can uh and then you can go after me
chicken we spared no expense uh for the
second time do we have the cameras live
at the by former vice president by
if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or Trump and you
ain't black
my butt needs white man
put it on backwards this time and if you
have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or Trump and you ain't
black all right bringing him back by the
way she's you can't see it but she's
taking a lot of body blows here this has
been a little bit rough for Caitlin
Collins
thank you very much for that all right
let's see let's see what the question is
Jennifer what's your question tonight
good evening Mr President title 42 is
expected to expire tomorrow yep our
Southern border and now our northern
border are experiencing record migration
I wonder why we learned on May 2nd that
the Biden Administration plans on
deploying 1500 troops to the southern
border do you agree with deploying
troops to the border and how will a
trump Administration slow down the rate
of money
there's a lot of BS the truth that's a
very fair question especially they're
behind the scenes they're not on the
board for me you're going to have tens
of thousands of people pouring into our
country even the judge you know the
judge overruled them when they wanted to
terminate it early and he said you know
that you better extend this thing the
judge in Texas said I hope you're going
to retrieve this but this is my policy
that they're letting terminate because
they lost in court they wanted to go
earlier you're going to have millions of
people pouring into our country right
now at a level that nobody's ever seen
before these people are sick anybody
that wants this to happen to our country
they're destroying our country we know
his answer here this is bad right so
Biden already just just to give you some
facts Biden already has two times as
many border encounters As Trump did
during his entire time in office we
should ask him to take the front door
off his house we should absolutely do
that right so currently over 5 million
encounters Trump's grand total for
Border encounters was 2.4 million also
Greg Abbott let's bring up this tweet
from him I saw this earlier today so
great work team hey I had no idea no
idea it was in a wheelchair I just
thought he was really short damn tree so
Greg Abbott says great work by Texas
National Guard and Texas DPS Biden sent
1500 troops to the border to do
paperwork Texas deployed trained
soldiers and Troopers to take real
action and respond to this crisis so
don't be fooled by 1500 people going to
the border to do paperwork behind the
scenes
do you want to hear him a little bit
because this is a strong issue for
Donald Trump
we have to build some more because there
are areas like water going through a dam
there are some areas where a lot of
people are coming you'd close up and
they come into another and we started
another 100 miles of wall in fact I said
to my people if we start this and don't
finish it and then we had a rigged
election I'm sorry to say it the
election
[Laughter]
drink your whole drink we got to get a
refill make mine Yingling because I
can't handle these belgians they're high
alcohol look
a country has their borders
true there's never been anything like
that is happening to our country you
built about 52 miles
new wall when you were in office
it wasn't the complete wall one other
thing that with nobody likes to respond
to that with your immigration
this is what she does yeah
some of the wall was up there and it
would be laying on the ground arrested
rotten to Steel rusted rotten wood a
little and what the radical left crazy
Democrats did if there's a piece of wood
laying down a wall I built 30-foot walls
that go down seven feet into the ground
if there was a little piece of wood
sitting in the ground they said oh he's
not building a wall we already had a
wall because this is the game they're a
party of disinformation it's not a game
Mr President it's about 52 miles of new
wall one other immigration policy yeah I
built new walls I built new walls 52
miles hundreds of miles what I did is I
replaced other wall that was laying down
that was up and rotting in the ground
for 30 years some of it was steel that
you couldn't it was only about 52 miles
another immigration policy you had was
the zero I love its immigration policy
that separated families at the border if
you are re-elected are you ruling out oh
that is insane when you have that clear
and I don't thank you very much uh and
by the way please uh send in your love
for the team that's helped put this on
your side now that's the Flores consent
policy from 1997 which by the way said
that you could not detain children for
more than 20 days okay this is why
Barack Obama actually ended up starting
uh to separate children with their
parents because he saw keeping children
as a deterrent from people coming in
over the border the floor is consent
policy 1997 signed under Bill Clinton
was about children being detained at the
border just to be clear and by the way
this is one thing that was a huge point
of contention in the debate was that who
built the cages Joe let's see what he
has to say she's full of crap the city
is being swamped Los Angeles is I'm
pretty sure I'm right about 99 of it the
whole country is being destroyed
millions of people coming into our
country and you know what the number is
going to be in my opinion by the end of
the year not the four million that you
hear in the 3 million until I think it's
going to be 15 million people and in
these people they have no idea where
they come from they come from 129
different countries so far 120 not just
before that we talked to put a button on
that it sounds like what you're saying
is that you're not ruling out
re-implementing that immigration policy
I want to get to another voter Caitlin
wants to know she never just she always
has to get the last word in for sure
she's like nothing like perpetuating a
negative stereotype white lady
hello president thank you so much for
coming thank you um the current
Administration has made it clear that we
should continue to provide military
equipment to Ukraine so that they can
defend themselves do you support this
decision and how would you deal with the
increasing threat posed by Vladimir
Putin first of all thank you very much
it's really nice I would have never let
it happen it's an important question so
important because we're giving away so
much equipment we don't have ammunition
for ourselves right now from Afghanistan
we're giving away so much for the
interesting to start off no longer
matters if I were president this would
have never happened and even the
Democrats admit that Putin knew it would
have never happened and his pipeline
would have never happened a lot of
things would have never happened but
this would never have happened and all
those dead people of Russia it would
they wouldn't be dead today and all
those cities that are blown up and
disintegrated right to the ground that
wouldn't have happened okay you know
what I love that Donald Trump does what
he does because everyone knows here
about the UK everyone knows that you
Ukraine answer uh so we have a little
bit of I love that Donald Trump will
answer with specificity tonight here's
what he'll do he'll answer with
specificity he'll disabuse people of a
certain notion that the the moderator or
the conductor whatever you want to call
her uh tries to instill in the audience
and then he drives it home with
something unrelated but also leaves a
mark like there was tons of dead woods
and everywhere that this is what
happened I replaced it they say 52
that they play they didn't want to fund
it he'll go through it and then be like
termites and then go back just so and
then people remember that that's right
and uh he's very very good it's called
anchoring yes exactly
I don't know any Democrats who have said
May 11 through 13th New Brunswick New
Jersey her question is would you
continue to give Ukraine money and
weapons if you're elected what's the
answer I have a very good relationship
with uh president zielinski because as
you know he backed me up with the with
the phony impeachment impeachment the
perfect call
the president didn't do anything wrong
so
I happen to like yeah that's right and
it was I was totally exonerated by the
way just a waste of time when I cut to
that shot he goes don't silent don't
side profile her that's cruel I'm
helping you it's not fair to her don't
go to side profile folks that's mean
woman named Nancy here
I would sit down let me just put a dice
away uh if I'm president I will have
that War settled in one day you hear you
said wow
the answer um
solved the problem talked about this
Ukraine is a perfect example he had
eight years of Obama and then he had
three years of Donald Trump one last
year was engineered of course that's the
number they try to point to as far as
what they try to point to us as failure
for presidency is the engineered
pandemic of cobit
um and then you have another after the
show of four years of Biden there's a
very start contrast let's talk about
International policy because the idea is
this guy is just such a loose cannon
that we're less safe hey what happened
under uh Barack Obama something
something Crimea oh yeah that's
something something is it pronounced
something something Georgia right and
then what happened oh nothing and then
we had Ukraine afterwards because anyone
who's been in a schoolyard knows that
crazy beats big every time you just have
to be a little bit crazy that's right
there's value in that yeah even Kim
Jong-un Kim Jong was going like I I
don't know I don't know this guy I don't
know what he's gonna you forgot Syria
they
kidding the
wrong the things they try to attack him
on people like him and then what they
try and use as this sort of Fail-Safe
like yeah but International policy you
need someone with an even temperament
he's proven them wrong
either way describe the world the way
that describe the world is not what we
see in our everyday life right it just
doesn't we're just like I know what are
they talking about they think that most
Americans are going come on you better
say yes you're going to give money to
Ukraine yeah I just don't like Jim
Brewer for some reason like a bit better
say yes it's gonna give money
I still respect him today uh he made a
tremendous mistake maybe he met his
smart guy right I remember he said he
was smart she was smart they said he
said president XI of China right is
smart Okay 1.5 billion people he's the
rule of 1.5 billion people I said he's a
smart guy how dare he say he's smart of
course he's smart they want you to say
he's a stupid person okay he's not a
stupid person he's very smart he's very
cunning and Putin made a bad mistake in
my opinion what was his name let me ask
you something really quickly okay and
I'd like to see maybe we can put uh I
guess we can't put this to a poll but
you can tweet me and you can use the
hashtag Critter Town Hall
um would you rather a world where Donald
Trump
Donald Trump starts with the
presupposition that Putin and XI
xingping are smart or would you rather a
world where former Vice President Joe
Biden assumes they're dumb
in which world are you safer hmm good
question please stop because if he's
going to be a war criminal where people
are going to go and grab him and execute
them you know who was smart he's going
to fight Hitler correct doesn't mean I
like him right I think Einstein was an
doesn't mean he's dumb right
or settled and I'm not talking about the
money either I'm talking about all the
lives that are being the number of
people being killed and that was far
greater than you're here when they blow
up a city and those buildings come
pouring down and then they say two
people were injured no no hundreds and
thousands of people are being killed and
we have to get that War settled we have
more with former president Trump right
after this we're going to take a quick
break in the way back with questions
occasionally we have commercial breaks
we have a commercial break if you want
to go no but didn't we um we have that
uh we have we got a new we got a new
intern right with title 42 yeah yeah
ending and I think we were a little
preemptive what we what you did Gerald
the CEO he's a new CEO it might have
been just it might have been illegal it
was my point but uh we did want to we
have the new uh intern here yes
uh-huh and we just wanted to sometimes
we like to profile people telling your
story so did you you came through with
the golden ticket sweepstakes yeah was
that it oh oh see I get vaccination
what is your experience how did you get
the the internship right people want to
know yeah I crossed the border and they
say okay yeah that's not no that's not
um no it works I'm sorry I I may have
made a mistake yeah we don't care about
covid do you have can you do research
can you do overlays
see yeah
later next time yeah we appreciate it um
golden ticket sweepstakes really that
seems like a nice guy yeah not my finest
moment no Gerald I'll do better you're a
horrible CEO well most of the time guys
I'm gay
I think we do have uh we do have a
commercial break okay we have a brief
commercial break and we'll be back after
that these gentlemen have to go to the
bathroom I do and again you can use the
promo code Crowder Town Hall later with
credit.com mug club or you can send your
email of proof of any right wing
streaming subscription in the last year
you can send that email to freemud club
ladderwithcrowder.com and we'll give you
three months free if you don't like it
you can bounce
try it
we think about it we don't know let's go
I think we have a a sponsor and a quick
commercial break
[Music]
so dude what are you doing man oh I'm
trying the new pudding from my Patriot
Supply so I got to admit it's okay it's
not great dude you're not supposed to do
it like that you got to put water in it
man how much have you eat
um
all of them
oh my gosh here try that that's better
come on instructions
oh that's much better of course it's
much better man you know you're gonna
have to buy some to replace that right
right I'll just go to prepocrowder.com
and get a three-month Supply perfect
you're probably gonna have to do that
twice Yakuza what in the world are you
doing are you serious from pancakes
no I'm fine thank you there's a gag
reflex when you need it
get ready for now that's what I call
Trump in this compilation your favorite
President makes these hits his own
Coco chasing GDP the median income is a
better metric and who can forget the
Pete butt gig song Splish Splash they
were taking a bath and it was a couple
of eggs voted on by the attendees at the
weekly White House talent show this
collection is sure to make you want to
get up and dance Nicki don't lose my
number
might replace patch with someone else
and Mike I haven't decided to support
the police because they work really
really hard news
it's a fake news
b-i-g-c
that's how you spell Hillary b-i-g-c
ity for Hillary welcome to the local
California
[Music]
there's a homeless face
poop all over the place lots of poop now
that's what I call Trump
for details
so how can I help you doctor my husband
and I have tried everything
try and get pregnant
pedestrians
I do have something that's worked in the
past
[Music]
okay
I think I feel something
wow
thank you Doctor you're very welcome
every time
paid for by the greatest president in
the history of the world
side effects frankly may include
being fantastic
[Music]
all right let's quickly go to CNN I
think they're both standing up now I
think so let's let's see right there
though because the presidential records
act which is not well known to a lot of
people
just so you understand the presidential
records Act is not criminal I took the
documents excuse me who else took them
Obama took them bikes and took them
oh he didn't the difference the
difference here
[Applause]
even Jimmy Carter even Mike Pence had
some documents and he's a very honorable
guy you reference but you know who took
him more than anybody is Joe Biden he
has 1800 boxes
[Music]
Mr President to actually set the record
straight here oh you did they took
documents including president or vice
president Pence when they realized they
had documents they turned them back over
the difference is that you waited to
turn yours over and it was a year and a
half excuse me excuse me these documents
one question
that's what it included
they had not been turned over yet they
didn't raid Biden's house you know what
happened they put him in the house
that's the one with the Corvette with
the documents running all over
fact because Donald Trump had them
locked up in boxes labeled classified
Joe Biden had them next to his midlife
crisis
I cannot
and even Democrat Senator to say I can't
believe it no I went by the presidential
records act and we were negotiating with
Nara that's not what it says
here's what he should do once though
Donald Trump you should say tell me what
it says go ahead take your time do that
you do that it'll end your career yep
it's a special counsel investigating
your document situation also President
Biden's document situation when it comes
to your documents did you ever show
those classified documents to anyone not
really I would have the right to by the
way they would Declassified after not
that I can think of let me just tell you
I have the absolute right to do whatever
I want with them I have the right I was
negotiating with narid you know what
Nara is the National Archives extremely
extremely left group of people extremely
left
extremely left that RBF owned my house
they didn't raid the house of Joe Biden
they didn't raid Obama Joe Biden did it
anymore subpoena to get those documents
back
150 bucks but that's the question that
investigators have I think is why you
held on to this documents
are you ready
do you mind watch this I would like for
you to answer those drinks very simple
things that's why I asked it it's very
simple that you're a nasty person
I was negotiating and we were talking to
Nara that's Washington to bring whatever
they want they can have whatever they
want when we left Washington we had the
boxes lined up on the sidewalk outside
for everybody people to take good
pictures
and the GSA government service the GSA
was the one taking them they brought
them down to mar-a-laga we were
negotiating with Nara all of a sudden
they raid our house
when Biden had his documents he won't
give back the 1850 boxes and you're
going to find some real gems in there
in the documents the National Archives
reached out to you to get your documents
back why did you not turn them over when
you got us because you would negotiated
with them she's hanging in there
we were negotiating with Nara
but they've got to love our constitution
a little bit more because and they
shouldn't red flag it by the way very
nice people we were negotiating with
Nara and that's what the presidential
records Richard Nixon surprisingly had
problems and he had a lot of problems
dealing with Nara and they ended up the
historians
presidential records act just for this
kind of a thing we were dealing with
them excuse me
excuse me we would have done it but all
of a sudden they raided the house now
why haven't why hasn't the FBI raided
Biden but I just explained to you why
it's because they murdered the
government that they had those documents
and had them come and get the doctors
do though when it comes to documents do
you still have any classified documents
in your possession so mad are you ready
do you you ready no I don't have
anything I have no classified documents
and by the way they become automatically
Declassified when I took them but why do
classes let me ask you a question why
who has to do that who gets to do that
the president in China they're
Declassified if he chooses to say hey
take a look at this yep
I need to stop you right there because
there's no evidence of what you just
said there what you're referring to
there is an office that he had no no
after leaving the vice president he had
a temporary office but I want to ask
about another investigation if you don't
know the subject
[Laughter]
you're facing which is the one that's
happening in Georgia where they are
investigating their your efforts to
overturn the election results in the
state of Georgia perfect phone calls
this is a great country because this is
what the center of that this descent
Brad raffensberger yeah sure given the
fact that there are indictments expected
to come in that case this summer is that
a call you would make again today yeah a
cold question in the election I thought
it was a rigged election I thought I'd
had a lot of problems I had every I
guess he's Secretary of State I called
listen to this there are like seven
lawyers in the call many of them from
there were having a call we're having a
normal call nobody said oh gee he
shouldn't have said that why if this
call was bad I questioned the election
was bad no that's not what he said we
just heard the audience
votes because the election was rigged
exactly election contract and if this
call was bad why didn't his lawyers yeah
the place where the pipe burst and they
took out these sorry not suitcases
because we'll be fact checked the cases
that look remarkably like carry-on
suitcases with ballots yes During the
period of time where they said a
pipeline
allegedly
he said come on you know there was fraud
yes that's that's the context
you vote and I should note that there is
no evidence
I want to get back to the audience so Mr
President because those are false claims
you're making about what happens
here and he's an Undeclared voter from
Hollis he voted for you in 2020. Jordan
what is your question for president
Trump tonight Mr Trump thank you very
much from every 80s movies
yeah I'm looking for somebody very good
but it sounds like a government
interference in private business but
I've seen Republicans going after us
like DeSantis after Disney what would
you do as president to protect us from
government interference really want to
protect you all of these fake
investigations of me are about election
interference good job they think because
I'm leading Biden by 11 points seven
points nine points I'm leading to
sanctimonious by oh a lot
just relax and take it easy and think
about the future future because right
now his future is not looking so good I
will tell you this we is really putting
it to Biden but he's putting it to
himself
yes the definition of a pressure fighter
though yeah and by the way the way he
got out of Afghanistan was the single
most embarrassing moment in the history
that is correct that is correct that's
right and the media never talks about it
oh let's see does she defend this while
we're in front of the voters here in New
Hampshire and New Hampshire this is a
fundamental question for you you're
running in the 2024 race if you are the
Republican nominee and you are in that
2024 race will you commit tonight to
accepting the results of the 2024
election yeah if I think it's an honest
election absolutely yeah
[Applause]
the woman answer it again if I think
it's enough
with Elizabeth Warren on Election
interference and election fraud but back
then you said it was Russia remember
that every single Democrat refused to
accept the results of the 2016 election
they didn't ask those questions
[Applause]
correct so not committing the 2024
election results
important conversation with voters to
hear and to have thank you to our
audience and to our hosts I feel like
we're biased Watchers of course we're
bias Watchers but I want to see what
CNN's commentary is because they're
gonna have to run interference over here
yeah it was a bloodbath she had she had
no handle on it oh there you go at least
they yeah look he even pursed his lips
he's like yeah thank you it was like
Bill Burr mockings I'm like dude I'm so
good yeah yeah you did great that you
only just ruined your career right
you'll be back you think you're gonna be
saved by your white pants shoot God he
looks so tired and yet he's just as
combative as ever yeah like not an inch
does he give and Anderson
oh God first of the 2024 presidential
campaign is now in the books he's going
to be a dentist almost from Washington
and it was an interesting night uh Mr
Trump's first lie was told just seconds
into the night here we go 2020 election
was quote a rigged election and by the
way it's only a lie because CNN says so
right
the threat to vice president Pence about
Pence's ability to overturn the election
about covet about the economy and more
he called a black law enforcement
officer a thug he said people here in
Washington DC at Chinatown you try and
make it a racial thing that's
unbelievable he was the only person who
killed someone on January 6. other than
the five people that you guys said wow
he had to throw in that yeah he called
the black he called a black man a thug
who shot someone from how many yards
away was it was it 30 was it 30 yards
away no no no no the black officer five
feet but I mean but I mean that's so
unnecessary that's exactly why CNN loses
I'm sorry Ashley Babbitt is crawling
through a window he could have gone
Federal jury found him libel of sexually
abusing you
you
you this right there
is a lot that's a lot he wasn't she said
he was just found guilty of sexually
abusing him that's a lie he didn't
sexually abuse anyone the journey it was
it was sexual battery this okay
okay clear I will it wasn't a Donald
Trump quote it was a stolen quote
initially Anderson Cooper this press is
the enemy of the people they flat out
lie in order to try and re-engineer
society when Anderson Cooper sorry
pardon my language if you have kids
watching they shouldn't be up this late
anyway that guy he was found guilty
of sexually abusing nope that is a lie
and you either have to believe that
Anderson Cooper is so dumb he doesn't
know that it's a lie or he is
deliberately trying to run interference
because his little friend who he
probably has cocktail hour with or wind
down Wednesday parties with just got her
hat handed to her that is a lie it's not
even close to the truth it's not even
close to the truth so you're so sexual
abuse is not the same as sexual battery
then it's just battery and defamation
right yes I thought it was more the
defamation thing but really quickly we
we did run the commercial for uh prep
with Crowder I just wanted to make sure
that we we got that part can you grab
that for me Brian yeah
grab that big case right there really
quickly bring the big thing over to him
there's a great deal if you go to prep
with Crowder uh prep oh we have a
different uh discount code going on
right now yeah you get 200 of free uh
emergency food kit it's survival gear
yes free survival go with the three
months can I open it supplies no don't
we got four of those that's just no
that's a placeholder how long will this
last me that's where that's where our
intern stores is tobacco pouches I
didn't know yeah that is fermented for
months
for that thing but it is
200 free of survival because they have
the balls to sponsor the show it's the
only sponsor that we've run on this show
I think for weeks by the way right now
so uh do it's you can go and buy these
things like at Costco but the truth is
you get a better product Better Price
her stuff works and you don't need to
worry about some zombie apocalypse I
live through the ice storm Montreal
where I mean I remember it was uh in the
dozens if not hundreds eventually people
died you have the earthquakes that
happen in California any natural
disaster you should have enough water
for a couple of weeks you should have
some way to heat some food and have a
couple months or three months of
emergency food everyone should have it
you don't have to be some kind of a
prepper let's see what uh three three
months in this in this three months
three months and 200 worth of survival
gifts wow feels nutritious a person who
from the time
can I take this off you can take it off
now yes I apologize I mean unless you
need it there
intentionally to his supporters and
plans to do that and I don't really see
anything that's changed directly I mean
between when he left the White House and
today so his aides can say what they
want but some things did change the
economy tanked and Americans know it so
your guy and yes I mean your guy is
losing your guy is losing you just said
think about that for a sec you know
George St Pierre used to do this where
people give him crap where every
opponent he would face he was a fighter
and some people would talk trash right
and George St Pierre came at it with the
idea of you know if I just say my
opponent sucks then that means I suck so
no matter who he would say he's my most
dangerous opponent he's the best guy I
fight he's dangerous and I have to plan
for him what they're saying right now is
Donald Trump is so how bad must your guy
suck yeah if he's losing to him that's
amazing yeah exactly you're saying that
this guy is a liar he's going to speak
Trump is really a guy who gets Biden
elected if that happens no no no no no
no no Donald Trump is beating him by
bigger numbers
using he beats him if there's an
election today I do yes 100 I mean
assuming that it's a fair and honest
election which you know is anyone's yeah
Donald Trump said basically saying like
you're telling me by the way they're
going to January 6. by the way back to
them I told you they would say this man
of them are great people I said that
they would say it was a beautiful day
watch them bring that up drink and it's
really what voters who are not in that
room think about it look he is who he is
and he is who he would vote for him hold
on let me say this let me let me repeat
he is who he is better than you yeah
41-48 if held today they would vote for
him things to see though in the sad
laughter
in the audience
party and so welcome to the Trump
Paradox
um CNN reached out to Republican
Undeclared voters in New Hampshire
um that is a honest reflection of
Republican beliefs in New Hampshire
which is how to touch you are with them
what did I tell you remember what I told
you at the beginning of the show maybe
we can bring it back up for mug Club I
said they are going to fundamentally
start with the presupposition which is a
lie they are not going to acknowledge
that all of the recent polls have not
only Trump beating Biden but beating him
by a greater margin than Rhonda said
wherever you line up that's just a fact
and they right now are calling it the
Trump Paradox this is what they want
they want you to try and have a civil
war within the Republican party where
you go oh maybe I want Trump but
DeSantis is more electable here's the
beauty right now you can vote for and I
don't care who it is vote in the primary
for who you want to be president because
right now either one wins Donald Trump
by a slightly wider margin than Rhonda
Santos I told you they wouldn't
acknowledge it because they want to try
and act why like the Maga Republicans
they want to try and paint the Donald
Trump voters at so extreme that they
should be separated off right sort of
pulling like a Patriot with Mel Gibson
pick off the Commander's first pick off
this very strong faction the faction by
the way that would vote for him over to
santis by double digits they want to
paint them as Maga extremists so it's
the Trump Paradox the Trump Paradox is
he's beating your guy period full stop
and buy a little bit more than the
scientists there's no Paradox but their
idea is to get Republicans who are
moderate to say you know what maybe it's
not worth more of this this is so
fatiguing that we should just vote for
Biden so we don't have to deal with
crazy and that is to say that people
aren't going to be outraged and angry at
how unfairly and how much they're being
lied so think about it this way think
about it this way they already had their
chance to go uh I don't really want to
vote for Donald Trump let's vote for
Biden he's the safe alternative look at
the wreckage that is following his press
residents yeah more matches so you
believe in borders more economic terms
more Strife in war in the country
where's code pink all of these things
right all of these things are happening
so you no longer have that and I think I
was wrong when I said that earlier on
where I said not tonight but earlier on
in this I was like I don't know if Trump
hasn't Jerry found him liable for sexual
abuse and yeah and they're replaying I
would replay most of that CNN yeah I
think they might have found him liable
for that I think that might be true they
found him liable for battery and
defamation which is also sexual there
doesn't necessarily well no battery
doesn't have to be battery does civilly
by the way and battery doesn't have to
be you've already battered me this is
the problem is they just say sexual
abuse is a general term look right
battery there's also a difference
between bad how did I lose my are you
me it's like between the cars
your phone yes God my research document
fell between them don't lose your
there's a huge difference between sexual
abuse and this is what they're trying to
do they're trying to make you go rape
sexual abuse and not actually look at
the case battery I have the definition
here this battery feels so good I mean
so bad uh by the way it's hashtag
Crowder Town Hall you get 10 off if you
join the night let's see what they're
replaying I'm curious to see what CNN
thinks is a win for them tonight to put
everything in he allowed us to put
nothing in Mr
presidential events here right now to
the truth you referenced the trial you
did not go to the trial and actually
testify do you wish that you had
testified it wouldn't have made a
difference this is a rigged very true
this was a my lawyer said sir you don't
have to do it I actually said I think I
should it would be respectful they said
sir don't do it this is a fake story and
you don't want to give it credibility
one thing there you go one thing you did
do in this
we're going to bring up that clip again
for those who missed it uh Carol I keep
getting the uh e Gene Carroll just to be
clear e Gene Carroll the jury said did
not prove rape as a matter of fact she
didn't really prove anything other than
sort of defamation just to be clear and
they were pretty liberal with the term
battery again they changed the statute
of limitations but uh oh no hold on we
have a little let's we have a little one
two lanyards we need to talk in politics
we need to just stay out we don't want
anyone to watch me on camera yeah I'm
not going to cut to it I just don't you
know he's he's young you don't want
people seeing absolutely not yeah
toolman's son is about as cute as they
get she just wanted to come in and see
yeah I know we're going along sorry Joe
sorry looks a lot like me which is weird
but anyway so she the jury son it's fine
it's fine keep going I'm sorry Jerry
said well you are you dude Moonlight is
a Milkman I do know
organic milk yes I milk it myself share
grass share it's a it's a way to skirt
the loss that's why my hands are so
rough and big the jury said she couldn't
prove rape she didn't prove rape and
again we're gonna roll the clip uh sexy
uh yes she's a lunatic they won't show
you this I think most people think of
rape as a I mean it is a violent assault
it is not I think most people think of
rape as being sexy I'm sorry what let's
take a short break of the fantasy so is
your hair we've got to take a quick
break if you can stick around we'll talk
more on the other side like that I like
that part
she looks like she's been sleeping on
that side and she just woke up so she
looks like Bridget Nielsen on a meth
Bender yes go ahead all right so they
they found him so sexual let's see what
it is right here so yes Mr Trump
sexually abused Miss Carol let me read
for you what that could be here's a
quick quote from the judge anything from
a gentle but unwanted peck on the cheek
to stabbing somebody with a knife could
be battery for purposes of a civil case
like this one so in other words believe
me greeting my aunt at Thanksgiving
kissing her on the cheek or the guy in
Warriors saying maybe we should run a
train on you they're both the same
that's the point right that's a very
broad term and by the way it's not the
same term state to state they're the
same damages the damages what they train
is the damages are for defamation which
by the way is what happened with with uh
uh what's the name of the the
professional uh Stormy Daniels yes
that's what happened they tried to say
that he defamed her but he couldn't have
defamed her that's why she owed his
attack attorneys fees because she said
it never happened to call her a liar
can't be defamation because she admitted
to lying a peck on the cheek is sexual
battery if you wear your genitals on
your cheek that is true right yes so
that's old genital Larry that's right or
you have herpes on your cheek I can't
remember what it is anyway maybe just
demonstrated on one I'm just kidding
yeah you really must be sick he already
touched me with his big fingers yeah I
can still feel them on my shoulder so
he's let's go to librarian stand in
whoever that is on CNN the rule of law
the justice system now they're here
Capital Hill Police Officer a thug we've
already talked about it was he killed
somebody who wasn't a threat what do you
call that I expect that bitch's
stockings to roll up under a house
[Laughter]
people were outraged by it and I would
end with this no you were who thinks
they could be you were Wicked Witch of
the Green Room against him you just saw
tonight what you're up against on a
debate can I just add one thing on the
best Christie just no Dana because you
had nothing seriously considering
running
what Chris former president said about
Ukraine and Russia in detail and what
Christy said was Donald Trump
interesting Dana your floor you're
creating 24 hours he said despite how
ridiculous this is I suspect he would do
it by turning over Ukraine to Putin
Putin's puppet so let's go to Anderson
and New York Anderson James you ignorant
across the partisan Spectrum van Jones
Christian soltis Anderson David Axel
Lucifer Griffin David Urban also joining
us as Florida Republican Congress oh so
this man from The Shield
everybody's trying to look super smart I
mean in one way my thoughts were
summarized by the previous panel
um but I will say anyone who has been
paying attention and expected Donald
Trump to be anything what he other than
what he was tonight uh really has
misread the situation that is who he is
and uh awesome
this is childish and ad hominem but it
looks like his spread collar is
rejecting his neck that's fair holding
on for dear life that button show up and
say you know I fought this I really
don't like Axelrod now I should have
done a few things differently that might
have been good political he's got a weak
chin I'll give him that he's got a weak
chin I'll give you that and that sort of
which that authentically who is who
Donald Trump is but it does underscore
one thing and I don't usually
he's out of the guy from The Shield in
that guy he is letting his Michaelis yes
that's it Michael chicken he's letting
his brows grow out and I appreciate it
but if you're a politician and you're
just willing to blow through facts
did someone say
love your version of the truth
um you know there's some advantage to
that and he's proved it this is the
Donald Trump that we have always known
at least who he is and if you are a
voter who is great repeat what the last
guy said yes she's the Republican
strategist and pollster right she is the
balance to this panel yeah right before
we go to socialist van Jones
and then I I want to go to our our panel
here for some thoughts and by the way I
know that we are biased the difference
is we let you know when we make all
references publicly available at ladder
with credit.com every single thing we've
told you tonight is accurate
I encourage you to fact check us
that wants to make the case look you
think I'm the chaos guy but actually
under Biden that's chaos right he talks
about the crime gas prices economy and
then he undercuts his own message that
he's actually not the chaos guy by
saying he would pardon the folks on
January 6th you can see what message
he's trying to draw he said some people
he said I don't know about all of them
because some of them got out of hand and
then he talked about antifa who you by
the way you you won't utter their name
it's like Voldemort you won't say black
you won't talk about black lives matter
anymore you won't talk about it
unimproved uh rerun reruns fake glasses
he doesn't need them and if you're
watching this Donald Trump is unfit
unwell unimproved and still good enough
to mess you up in a general according to
every single recent poll you dumb
bald-headed prick what does that say
about you unimproved he still beats your
guy by seven points you're being racist
in U.S courts of seditious conspiracy a
criminal Thug group called The Proud
boys that's an easy no I'm not gonna
pardon traitors he wouldn't even give
but not every single one of them was
found guilty dummy just like I wouldn't
say that every single member of antifa
is a basement dwelling prick it's mostly
accurate but it would be a lie for me to
say that that's all of them I'm sure you
showed up to a couple of meetings
I honestly found it jarring to watch um
and just kind of a question
is a great word Ukraine he basically
alluded to restarting the inhumane
family separation policy um by the way
her qualification was being on MTV's
teen moms and and then he made light of
sexual assault and even more
horrifyingly some of the audience
members
he
made light of fake news lying about
sexual assault
some important policy issues did come up
any Republican running for office or
considering running for president wants
to secure the Border they want to bring
down inflation they want to deal with
the economy they want strong American
leadership abroad they will do that
without the chaos the insanity and
throwing our allies under the bus the
way Donald Trump
you know half the United States still
likes this guy right you heard John King
say he may be the next president United
States
right he may be the next president
United States so I know there's this
this you know he's a terrible human
being it's the same God that is but it's
the same guy when he gets a close-up
look okay
bring him up again Michael checklist
tell me this isn't him yeah
that's actually him playing the Trump
advisor on the border now so at least
but Trump was in what's he doing on CNN
he's he's
it's method acting he did yeah
Trump advisor the movie's called Trump
advisor record rather than next is going
to be what's the name of the guy from
NYPD Blue who was also in uh Sons of
Anarchy he's hispanic Dennis oh no he's
just no not not Dennis I'm gonna stab
this that's on your eye
his name is super white but he's like
tall Hispanic NYPD Blue Gemma oh oh hey
Gemma oh oh um um um well I can't uh oh
man
in West Wing Jimmy Smith's Jimmy Smith
Jimmy Smith's yeah you nailed it I stole
it that's what they're gonna bring up
next
there he is can I just say something
really quickly the Jarred lady that was
speaking just a moment ago uh she said
oh you're going to start that inhumane
process of uh taking kids away from
parents okay let me just say two things
one if you don't want your kids taken
from you do not try to cross the border
illegally good point second point is do
you know why they do that because a lot
of people come across the border with
child sex slaves and say they're my
children to be able to get special
treatment and preferential treatment and
they separate you from the parents to
make sure that they're not gang raped
and also to make sure that the story
checks out so maybe if you did a little
research you would understand they're
actually trying to help
sex slave children Escape who else in
this room is a what are you a liberal
over there who else is officially Jarred
I consider myself
I was out of line to a jarring degree
correct
I can't believe that a professional
woman on news set up her response on a
panel with I was very jarred
you shouldn't play with the big boys
then sweetheart she said I found a
jarring I found it jarring I find it
like like she just came back from that
time warp an event horizon can we run
the fact check 2 on the wall we actually
have exclusive video of Donald Trump uh
and some of the the work that he
actually did on building the uh the wall
oh do we yeah we do let's go to it now
my
and at least they've got Republicans oh
oh that's right oh oh hold on a second
oh yeah hold on a second we have a
break-in
hold on
if we don't that's okay
oh we don't have it never mind Joe Lewis
will die wait wait wait wait they can't
hear you I'm going to eat him oh no no
please carnivores never mind I was wrong
Gerald was calling for something I don't
have I thought oh okay he doesn't have
it it's one of my favorite things that
we've ever done if we could get that
that would be phenomenal it's it's it's
the dueling of the the beard edger this
is yeah there's a disaster because
initially with Ukraine Joe Biden wanted
to give Vladimir zlinsky by the way of
course I'm not going to eat a dog just
to be clear people in Moscow in Ukraine
here in the United States said this
invasion is wrong that Joe Biden reverse
courses do you do you want a victory I'm
just trying to respond to everything
that's been coming up on the table last
thing let me say this
um we spent 20 22 23 minutes talking
about January 6th oh we could have been
talking about a whole lot of other
issues instead of doing that for the
first half hour or so but let me be very
clear what was said in this town hall
about National guard troops that were
authorized by Clayton by Caitlyn was
wrong I'm on the oversight committee I
was in two hearings on January 6th can
we give CNN props for at least having
Republicans National Guard troops on
January 4. he followed up in the call
with then acting death Secretary of
Defense on January 5 trying to see where
the deployment was on those troops that
is testimony in the oversight committee
everybody testified an oversight
committee when Nancy Pelosi was speaker
of the house except one organization and
that was the Capitol Police Nancy Pelosi
would not allow that I'm telling well
I'm telling you notice he's the only one
who brought in actual facts corrected
correct and look what he brought up did
you read the book
well you can say anything it's not under
oath he's like I'm telling you what the
committee had what what is something
yeah
he testified to under oath
committee how are the facts you
acknowledge Donald Trump lost the 2020
election correct again we're going to
continue to talk about 22.
trunk snout that let me tell you
why most voters are frankly kind of
tired of y'all bringing this up
inflation
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
we had more than them tonight yes at any
given moment and the live ticker's
broken
that it did too I understand why some
people moving forward into 2024 a couple
of things are very very clear the nation
is there just like your skin Anderson's
overrun inflation is crippling every
family Republican Democrat independent
those are the matter
but at least CNN has three Republicans
no they have one one and two patsies
election and questions about the last
election and the Insurrection should be
part of the discussion now but since the
President also noticed they put up their
lower thirds and not his yep a rigged
election and he repeated against tonight
since uh he was the one who rallied the
crowd that that stormed the capital that
he celebrated tonight I want to ask you
this one thing because I was interested
when he was talking about his case uh
that was decided yes
and he said well that was rigged it was
a question
by the way this is I'll I'll come back
locations of election rigging should
they be trusted because their Trump
appointed judges or are they rigged too
listen every candidate that runs for
office everyone I've run for office
you're allowed to contest lower third we
all have that ability yeah well this guy
was still talking where's his lower
third things he's had the ability
where's his lower third where's his
lower third do we need a timer where's
his lower third what about the
2020 elections
still going where's his lower third okay
where's his lower third
what I mean by that people is
title these people have
people have titles they are professional
Talking Heads This is a man who is
actually serves as a representative of a
voting constituency the people and Van
Jones van Jones lower third let's hear
van Jones in real time in front of
millions of people it is very very
difficult yeah they changed it to give
him a second title it is incredibly
difficult uh to talk to somebody who is
going to say things sometimes they're
true sometimes they're not true I don't
think anybody here thinks that Donald
Trump is as a as a paragon of Truth
telling I thought Caitlyn did a
masterful job she's a matador again oh
my gosh hold on let me do this you might
as well against a bull at least he
referred to him as a bowl yeah let me do
this CNN didn't have the balls to do it
we will that's U.S congressman Byron
Donald's proudly representing the
southwest Florida District 19. you guys
wouldn't put it up we will good and
Anderson he didn't have to blow a guy to
get his Chiron well abuse
person who just once again
oh shut up
sexism here's the thing you know what
Gerald you would have been right if this
was 2016 people are tired of this
people are tired of women always
claiming the moral hydron by simply
saying I'm Jarred I'm Jarred I can't
sexual abuse because he pecked me on the
cheek I've been your Jarred right now
it's sexist that he just refuted her
with faction have you read the book it
doesn't matter no one cares that you
feel Jarred you're wrong you're wrong
chilling Jarred unnerving and disturbing
they all drive you nuts I actually would
say this is what we wanted I swear to
God if they bring up David axelrod's
lower third I'm gonna lose my mind
if I were as lawyers I'd be deeply
concerned he deserves a lower third less
yeah than David Axelrod anything that is
there anything that would exclude him
even if he don't do it is someone who
Republican voters want back in office
because of the things he did in terms of
policy like could he go out and kill
somebody could he is there anything that
would be that that you would consider
beyond the place talking
well this is what people want so those
piccadillos who are going to let alone
at the end of the day this is always
going to be at the hands of the voters
the voters are going to decide who they
want to support polling would dictate
that they want to support Donald Trump
by a wide margin in the Republican party
I will also say the ABC polling is
pretty clear that Americans were at
large want to support him this is the
best guy I've ever seen on CNN as far as
a republican he's the best they'll never
have him back never have him or if they
have him back they're going to stack the
deck like this hey let's have a white
this is what Bill Burr was talking about
on SNL let's have a white woman tell a
black man that he doesn't understand
what being what what being oppressed is
like no over the last couple of months
and it will be very interesting to see
do voters who may have forgotten what it
felt like for Donald Trump to be in the
spotlight was it jarring was it jarring
I hope it wasn't jarring or perhaps
rattling maybe maybe it was unsettling
dear God I hope it wasn't unsettling all
those words are used by people who've
never been punched in the face yes want
this rerun so that's what I was just
going to say look you know actually you
said if you left tonight you'd say he
did a great job you know because he
spoke to somebody
[Laughter]
also as good as the thing and the
Fantastic Four disappointing film but he
could have a great performance up a
little right he's going to need to speak
to those so let me just kind of clarify
something for you and then we're gonna
go to Mud Club and take your chats what
they just did I've talked about this
quite a few times because I got called
in by the way to the second floor at Fox
News and second floor is where the
executives were
um
what David Axelrod just did it's the
opposite of standard right you know the
old quotients in in comedy is I didn't
learn comedy when I learned how to write
I learned comedy when I learned how to
edit remember Phyllis Diller said that I
think Jay Leno repeated it I don't know
the original Source but brevity is a
soul of wit yes in cable news it's the
opposite what David Axelrod was has been
doing what van Jones has been doing what
Mrs Tweety Bird I've been Jarred is
doing is trying to buy up as much time
as possible before they ask a question
they're trying to buy as much take up as
much air time as possible when they have
an opponent who they know over matches
them I had this when I would appear on
Fox News uh there was I had a debate
segment for I want to say it was a year
with Alicia Menendez Senator Bob
menendez's daughter oh yeah and then at
a certain point she worked for a company
who said you probably shouldn't don't do
this anymore it was every Sunday
sometimes Tucker would actually host it
he would film host for Clayton Clayton
Morris I believe was his name
um and uh I think I was Chip something
rigs something rigs anyway I'm trying to
give you an Allison Allison Camerota so
they would do Fox and Friends Sundays
and I got called in one time because
what would happen is is they would say
things like well you know as uh someone
who's been raised in a political family
in Washington DC insert 30 seconds on
the clock and then rather than an
argument I remember one time
specifically it was tossed to me she
said something like and uh I don't know
if I don't know where uh Stephen got his
uh college degree in the in the
political sciences
um and I responded with Wow never
graduated grade school what's your point
and there was dead air
and I was called to the second floor
because I knew that that was the most
effective course of action was to say I
see what you're doing I see you right
now Ronnie James Dio this I said I
see exactly what you're doing I'm not
even going to address the rest of
psychobabble that you just spewed for 30
seconds to buy up time I'm going to
address what you thought was your
argument and try and make it look silly
so the audience sees this appeal to
Authority fallacy I got called into the
second floor I said you know you can't
do that I said what they said this has
been happening you know people been
complaining that you're too quick you're
too short not quick man quick waiter
they said you're too short with your
answers look there has to be a give and
take there has to be a back and forth
where you have to take some time they're
not they're not used to that this is how
we do things and sometimes it would even
put us in a quadrant view even though we
were in the same room one demo was with
Lanny Davis or might have been Doug
Schoen where they wanted us to seem like
we were in different cities and I
reached from my quadrant into his and
said high five I got called into the
second floor for that yeah they probably
didn't like that no it is it is a parlor
trick and they told me don't try and
keep the points brief which is what
resonates with people this is the
difference Donald Trump resonates with
people who will be voting for him that's
why you see the polls Whiting that's why
those people don't trust the polls they
have a way of doing things they told me
you need to do things this way when the
American public and by the way the
average viewer clearly has told them
they don't want it that way I was told
that I was being too short imagine that
they're going but can you take more air
time I'm going I don't want it yeah but
that's because you you as a performer
you just know that the minute you start
lying the minute you start thinking that
the audience is not as smart as you are
you are in big trouble yes and the
audience the biggest mistake you can
make as a performer is to think that
your jokes or your performance or what
you're saying is going to be over their
head and you have to dumb it down right
Hugh huge steak and that's what I see
with CNN all the time they say things
that people including the people that
watch CNN look at and go it's not jiving
with reality man you're trying to pull a
fast one on me that's what they do
especially when they start talking a lot
like Axelrod no I think you're I think
you're right that's just an important
technique just if you see someone saying
in 50 words what they can say in five
that person is likely dishonest that's
right what you should do if you want to
edu Gerald you know this when we do this
show we we've basically our blueprint is
watch what they do and let's do the
opposite they don't provide any any
evidence we're going to make sure that
all of our references are publicly
available everything is pre-taped and
edited we're going to do it live right
oh they want to take up as much time to
make one point as possible we're going
to give you two three or four and allow
you to then Deep dive it as much as you
want because they don't serve you they
serve themselves it's someone who likes
to hear themselves talk that's what you
saw tonight and you saw the con and by
the way of course Donald Trump likes to
hear himself talk but he is talking
directly to the American public he
wasn't talking to Caitlin Collins
tonight which I think was was a very
smart strategy on his unbelievably good
yeah look he didn't look at an example
of her so that you convince the people
watching you think you're going to
convince that Broadway to hairy forms
there's nothing you can do I can change
I bet you she walked off the stage and
said I'm with her I was Jarred this was
jarring for me and here's something I
wanted to kind of go around and then
we'll take some chats of course a lot of
cutter.com mug Club
um
here's the real value I would say in CNN
versus Fox News
uh and I just have to kind of be quiet
about it look you know I was there for a
few years okay
um at least with CNN
people see who he's fighting
I think Donald Trump understood that if
you he would appear on Fox News he would
give them a platform he would legitimize
them and he would legitimize the
underhanded attacks yeah I'm telling you
that when I was at Fox News
uh it was a Romney Obama election
it was made known in no uncertain terms
that I better get in line from me at
that point it was down to believe
Gingrich Romney Santorum when I told you
I wasn't wasn't a huge fan of any of
them for a political candidate I think
Rick santorum's a decent guy I spent
time with his family so I said well at
this point I think he would do better
with the Rust Belt voters than Mitt
Romney and I was right by the way and I
was told no no
Romney's our guy and if you go and watch
the coverage it was very clear they have
made it clear in no uncertain terms that
there is a hit out on Donald Trump to
try and kneecap him to try and take him
out because he is he is now for the
first time and maybe it's the result of
ego
light has been shined on Fox news right
now for what they are and tonight at
least Don sorry I was about to say Don
Lemon at least Donald Trump knew who he
was fighting that's important he knew he
was fighting out there he wasn't
fighting a ghost and he didn't want to
legitimize a fake conservative outlet
and by the way it's not just Fox News
you've heard us talk about this I'm not
going to go back through it again but
you know where we line up
it's very important and by the way
there's a huge value in having battle
lines drawn in having not saying that
all Republicans are good and all
Democrats are bad before you fence
sitters try and tell me the two parties
just a man go to a parliamentary system
see how that works out exactly but there
is a value in seeing a delineation in
team jerseys and going okay you know
what hold on at least I know where CNN
lines up because I've heard everything
that they've said and Donald Trump is
the other guy you have a whole panel of
people
a representative from Florida and Donald
Trump is the other guy whereas in Fox
News they would try and say well you
know it's like the Anna Navarro thing
I'm a republican except for every single
policy and I hate Donald Trump and he's
racist and I can't believe and Jones oh
and I'm Republican right there's no
that's so dishonest I this is why you
rarely hear us go after MSNBC other than
to laugh at Joy Reid's latest Swiffer
haircut it's I have no problem with
someone who says where they line up I
don't the biggest problem I have is with
turn codes is with portrayers is with
people who claim to be something that
they're not and at least tonight Donald
Trump didn't have to Grapple with that
and so I think that's a win for him now
I want to see where you guys line up
here tonight uh I will say this myself
I'm sorry I'm leading the witness
unless DeSantis takes it hard to the
media on Election uh on Election
Integrity unless DeSantis takes it hard
to the media on their bias
um and on you know for example the
double standard of classified documents
all that but particularly election
integrity
I would vote for Donald Trump in the
primaries if if Donald Trump performs
like he did tonight it is over I'm not
talking about performance I'm saying I
mean that's required for me that's
mandatory for Republican candidate to
say we need to have election Integrity
in this country so when I say
performance I don't mean just the
performance I mean answering the hard
questions I mean having the positions
that he holds and also being able to
point back and be like Donald Trump 2019
is what you'll be getting in round two
you'll be getting the economy that I
brought you for three years before covet
hit and before the world turned upside
down the most kind of jarring experience
this generation if I can borrow a term
has ever experienced you'll be getting
Donald Trump 2019 and it'll be more fun
than ever because the media has been
even more exposed and the Biden economy
has been more exposed and by the way
really quickly Joe Biden actually
tweeted out there were not fine people
on both sides of Charlottesville I don't
remember him mentioning Charlottesville
by the way uh the January 6 rioters were
not good people end of story now here's
the thing let's keep that up let's keep
that up what people try to say they're
the party of nuance Donald Trump said
but pardon some of the pardoned a lot of
them I don't know all of them some of
them got out of hand right that's
actually far more couch than saying the
January 6th rioters were not good people
but doesn't say there were peaceful
people there yeah the vast majority of
whom outside of federal agents did not
commit crimes that's a very broad brush
one is saying hey I think a lot of
people haven't gotten a fair shake the
other is an incitement to violence that
right there is an incitement of violence
because if you say that everyone there
January 6th by the way was it a quarter
million people it was over 200 000. I
know that some estimates had a close to
500 000 depending on who you let's use
the low number 200 000 a thousand you've
now told
the American public that
it's open season on them they're bad
people yeah let's other them let's
dehumanize them let's treat them
subhumanely let's do that that's what
that tweet does just did notice what he
didn't say be mostly peaceful because he
can't say that no come on Harris didn't
say that she said they could they should
continue riotic correct yeah that's the
proper response is what Kamala Harris
it's Eve look people want to act like
Joe Biden is a nice guy who's respect no
he's this is evil evil that right
there is evil and he should know
better if he's president of the United
States so let's hear Brian well first of
all the double standard is
jarring and I never use that word and I
never use I use it all the time okay
fine you have to drink my all right fine
I'll drink but it's just it's jarring
but look listen I got I got two things
to say tool man you have to drink don't
be even better if you were drinking from
a jar I I know but I I prefer my real
glass everyone I'm not a Pinterest wine
no of course not I'm not really this is
my real this is the way I really talk
actually I'm from England yes I find
that's jarring I don't know it should be
it's positively I'm sorry I hate to be
so unnerving but but you know if I could
be okay the one thing about me I'm full
of Verve yes yes oh right right in the
genitals
battery battery hit me in my genitals
keep using that voice see what else
flies your ways
I know in English accent I do believe
that was a Karma yes of course I know my
English accent makes him very horny well
it makes him break really really a gay
boy
it's men it's not gay if I'm speaking
this way it's gave him
about him no this is more Recreation
this is college
homosexuals okay sorry it's only getting
here smiling when you do it and you know
that now this we're looking in the eyes
or looking in the you could be frowning
but looking in there you can be smiling
and not looking in the eyes but you
can't be doing both go ahead I'm so
confused but I'm horny now listen oh
Lord here's what I'd say I like I like
that this is our the grand experiment is
Alive and Well democracy is alive and
well as long as we have this outrage on
both sides and we have all the stuff
including lies it's never been different
in our Republic
um but I will say this I do think Donald
Trump is the most divisive figure in
American politics it takes in the
history of our country if I had a choice
between Donald Trump and descent
DeSantis I'm voting for DeSantis however
that's a fantasy because if you think
the Santa has a chance in the primaries
against Donald Trump you got another
thing coming so at the end of the day
this is going to be a Redux this is
going to be a Redux it's going to be
Biden Trump once again
and um and I am I think that's very
winnable because you've got binding
scene is a proxy he volunteered as you
know tribute for Obama and you
have eight and you have three and you
have another four of Biden people see
the contrast uh I mean the media the
media will have to be working overtime
but it doesn't matter anymore but let me
say that it's like a monkey throwing
nobody watches them Trump I will
say this Trump makes people the left so
angry that it turns them into liars it
it they compromise everything they're
about they will do whatever it takes to
get that guy out because
oh
[Music]
it's going to be far worse in 2024
because guys we have to band together we
have to do whatever it takes to save
democracy and keep Donald Trump out of
office and they'll use that to justify
oh you're a trump supporter bang we
already saw them
Trump corrupts he corrupts the left he
corrupts the he corrupts mainstream
corporate media because they will do
whatever it takes and I think that they
are digging their own growth and you
just touched on something very profound
I think you're right and look by the way
Donald Trump has a lot of flaws you can
say the same thing about the Trump
sycophants who will never acknowledge
anything that he does that is a fault
but like you said he corrupts the left
they lose their mind and here's why
because no one would argue this right
including they just said it tonight
using words like chaos using words like
Donald Trump has no respect you know for
for the rule of law or order that's what
they'll say what do they mean to say
right ultimately the synonym for that
the word they mean to use is he's
uncontrollable and the left is obsessed
with control they want to control what
you eat they want to control what you
drive they want to control what your
state they want to control what level of
authority you have over your own
children over your own household they
want to control what you learn they want
to control who pays for what you learn
they want to control what you can charge
for rent or if you can charge at all
they want to control the past they want
to control they want to control the past
they want to control history they want
to control which history they want to
control what is considered the truth and
when that's not allowed they want to
control new legislation to determine
what is truthful and we just heard the
lies tonight Donald Trump is if there is
nothing else of value from Donald Trump
if you're a DeSantis person and by the
way I like both of them to be clear I
want both of them to play a role in
National politics also love the Flying V
yeah but Donald Trump and I'll leave you
with this and by the way you can go to a
lot of credit.com there's ten dollars
off at 79 annually if you use the promo
code Crowder town hall or if you never
got your mug if you signed up let's say
a few months ago and you know you
weren't able to get a refund you can
send in your screenshot proof of
purchase to uh freemud Club at
lottoscrediter.com and we will give you
three months free that's how we know how
to make it right look we are entirely
funded by viewers like you and a few
sponsors every now and then if there's
nothing else to take from tonight both
the left and the right are saying it but
in two different ways and you can like
this you can love it you can hate it you
can take it or leave it the left has
admitted they are obsessed with control
and Donald Trump is uncontrollable and
speaking of someone who is imminently
controllable uh before we go to mug club
uh and by the way if you're watching on
Rumble just hit that little button right
there right down there you hit that
button you get to keep watching for
another 30 45 minutes I don't know how
long we're going to be going tonight uh
let's check in uh our our last we spent
we spared no expense no we paid for it
um we have our own camera uh right now
uh at the White House check in what's
going on with uh President Biden and if
you have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or Trump and you ain't
black
is going down for his nap
ready for night night
if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or Trump and you
ain't black